はい 釈尊の語り方 もう時間ないんですね
まあ上書きでも大丈夫ですけど
釈尊は上のない師匠である
自分では言いたくない
いわゆるみんな聞きたいで
言いたいでしょ 教えたいでしょ
お釈迦様は逆 何も言いたくはない
何も教えておかないという気持ち
サッターデマヌスターは天然知略とは語る上手で相手を簡単に納得させる方です
お釈迦様 それはもう人中一なんです
喋る上手です 語り上手です
お釈迦様が語ったら 相手が必ず理解する
それぐらい能力があるんですけど
何か語りたいと思ってないんです
語ったものを相手が理解するからそういうわけですね
ブッダが世界に生命にプレゼンテーション術を持っているんです
だからもう私さえもブッダのプレゼンテーション術ですよ
そのままじゃないんですよ
もう 1万分の1にもなってないんです
お釈迦様のプレゼンテーション術は
人の心の動きを知り尽くしているから
いった能力です 心はどのように動くかとお釈迦様知り尽くしてますよ
あの 100分の1の隙間がお釈迦様見つかるんです
見つけてそっちに語るんです
あるいはわざと整理整頓して隙間をつけるんです
自分しかし 一方的に強引に語り続けることはなさらなかったのです
あなたは何を問いているのでしょうか？ブッダの教えとは何なのですか？などの問いに答えていないんです
お釈迦様は 理解能力のキャパシティの問題と
相手に話を理解したいという気持ちの問題が出てくるからです
私はこんなものだとお釈迦様は全然言いません
私の教えはこんな教えだ
なぜかというと キャパシティの問題
人間理解できないから
それから相手が聞きたくないなら
大きな差でしょう だからそれはない
では ブッダが何を語る
感情の渦巻きに巻き込まれている
巻きの生命はひどく悩んで苦しんでいる
外からの情報を取り入れて
その苦しみをなくしたいと思って受信するアンテナを張るんです
生命っていうのは見事にちゃんとアンテナ張ってるんです
みんなに読まれていないんです
このアンテナ この苦しみを何とかしたいというアンテナ
みんな張ってるんです
人の悩みによって受信アンテナが受ける波長が変わります
それで私が張ってるアンテナと
皆様各自で張ってるアンテナの波長が微妙に違うんです
だからそれぞれ苦しみは違いますからね
ブッダがその波長に合わせて情報提供するんです
ですから ブッダに語られたら聞くしかないんです
聞きたくないと思ったって
自分がアンテナを張ってるんだから
アンテナ張って電源オンにしてるんだから入ります
だから何でも喋るんじゃないんですか？相手の苦しみのアンテナに合わせて語っている
あの辺では聞きたい 知りたい
理解したいという要求に応じているので
視聴率は必ず上がります
だからお釈迦様のやり方はもう人が聞きたい
知りたいことに答えているでしょ
だからお釈迦様の場合は視聴率は抜群
もう 600 人が住んでいても
一人も責払いさえもしなかったんですよ
居眠りするところが すごいコミュニケーション術なんです
しかし 私が言ったでしょ
知りたいことを言うと悪行為だと
そうじゃないの しかし
俗世間のやり方とは違います
悩みをなくす方法を教えているんです
人にその能力がないんです
悩みたくないんだけど
悩みなくす方法を知らないんです
それを教えてあげているんです
ですから ブッダに耳を傾けると
人は確実実に成長します
ブッダと言語の問題 言語が伝えたいことを明確に伝えないんです
流動性落ちるんです 意味が
しかし 不完全な言語を見事に見事な技で使用していたんです
お釈迦様は これから言語の技を教えます
言語っていうのは あのあの
お盆でカエルを持っていくような感じで逃げてしまいますよ
意味が逃げるんです 言葉だけ残る体
だからもう難しいんですよ
喋るの なのでお釈迦様はその問題を解決していたんです
たくさんの同義語を使うんです
お釈迦様の経典を読んでみてください
同義語はずっとなりすしてるんです
日本語はできない 日本語はそんなに同義語はないんです
ものすごいたくさん使うんです
そうするともうどうにもならなく理解しちゃうんですよ
あれ あの言葉の意味がわからないと思ったら
そぎ落とす単語があるんだから
それちょっとあのそぎ落とす単語ありますよ
例えば悟ったという場合は
チャックンウダパーリ
ニャーナンウダパーリ
ヴィッチャーウダパーリ
パンニャーウダパーリ
アーロークウダパーリ
5つの言葉で同義 なんで何言ったかわからなかったと言えないんですよ
だから悟った ちょっと聞き取れなかったと
聞きなかった ありえないんです
チャックンウダパーリ
ニャーナンウダパーリ
ヴィッチャーウダパーリ
パンニャーウダパーリ
アーロークウダパーリ
5回言うと この同義語の技があるんです
テーマポイントを先に発表するんです
それすごい技です あのね
あなた方にはあの 高速になる4つの項目を教えますよと言った途端
あ  4つ何？と聞きたくなる
時々私もそれ項目言ったら一つ忘れたりするでしょ
4つですけど それで皆様なんのことなく
あの3つなんですけど
もう一つはと聞くでしょうに
やられてるんです あの
私はインチキやってるわけじゃないんです
本当に話の途中で忘れちゃったんです
自分が忘れたにも関わらず
皆様方はもうちょっと言ったの
3つしか言ってないでしょ
もう 1個あるんだよという聞きたくなってるんで
だからお釈迦様の技っていうのはすごいんです
何項目が 何項目があるのかと先に飛ぶんです
あ 前はちょっと間違えた
あのテーマ 今日は これこれについて語ります
今日はどんなものがあっても
勝利を得る方法を教えますよとか
そういうふうにお釈迦様はテーマを先に読むんですね
それから項目を先に読むんです
それから定義するのです
言葉をという 定義しちゃうと逃げないんですよ
意味は 言葉の単語の意味は逃げないんです
提案した項目を解説し
説明する 次に提案した項目は
これはこの意味 これこれやと説明してあげる
で語ります ブッダは説法ではなく対話です
ブッダは説法しません
相手が必ず参加しているんです
聞くへと 聞き流しは不可能です
対話ですから 相手の質問に問いに答えるのであって
ねえねえ これを聞いてくれよという気持ちは絶対ダメです
あのね いい話があるんだから聞いてくれ
聞いてくれよ 迷惑ですとか
お釈迦様はそんな調子は全くない
人の問いに答える 質問があったら答える
対話の流れで相手が知るべき情報を出ない場合
別な見方もあると提案します
例えば対話しましたんだけど
まとめが答えにはなってない
そうするとお釈迦様は本当はね
まあそれは見る別の見方がありますけど
聖者が見る見方もありますよということで
一応相手の人があのお釈迦様
この聖者から見る見方って何でしょうかねと聞くんです
そうするとまた対話が始まります
それでお釈迦様はまた語ります
別な見方を知りたいと頼んだ
頼んだならば語るので
対話形式のままで話は進む
お釈迦様に自分の意思で喋りたいことがあっても
お釈迦様はこれを対話形式に持ってくるんです
なんかすごいというか
なんかわからないんです
話を間でも質問を受ける
ブッダが相手に質問して理解を確かめる
ブッダが相手に質問するんですよ
君 答えてください 好きなように
これはどう思う？これはどう思う？相手にこうやって理解させながら
確認しながら話を持っていくんです
用語を乱用しない  皆様も同じで
日本では喋る場合 用語ばっかしですね
特に仏教の場合は もう私よりすごい用語
時々質問される時でも
なんだらかんだら聞いたことない仏教用語来るんですね
私は使ってないですよ
仏教は だから仏教知らないと思ってるんですかね
だから下手なへとそ感です
でも ただ用語を使う場合は
必ずその定義を定めておくのです
時々用語を使いますよ
どうしようもない その時
必ず定義をして意味を定めておくのです
最終的に美しい言葉でポイントを集約する
お釈迦様の場合は  1時間
2時間徹夜して喋っても
終わったところで全部集約してくれるんですよ
芸で歌で これがポイントですと
とても美しいんです これ覚えられます
それでブッダが何を言ったのかというと
ブッダの集会失礼ですけどね
題目が唯一コミュニケーションの達人ですが
ブッダを完全に理解したとは言えないのです
ブッダが唯一コミュニケーションできた人なんです
我々には不可能です なのにブッダを理解したというのは完全に
これはないのです 声明一の能力で語られても理解できなかった
誤解され 誤解されたということがあったんです
また 釈尊は自分が悟ったことを一切を語ったではなく
人間の問いに答えたんです
だからそういうコミュニケーションなんです
お釈迦様さえも誤解されましたから
あまり気にしないでくださいよ
相手の私の気持ちはやっぱりわかってないんだ
といったっても 死ぬまで一生懸命頑張ってください
なかなか ありえないことです
それでお釈迦様が自分の悟りの内容を全部語ってないんです
人の問いに答えたんです
だからお釈迦様 私のことを理解してくれと思ってないんです
ということをブッダの集合です
しかし 感情と刺激のみを求める人間に応じたのではなく
苦しみをなくす道を語ったんです
皆様 この笑いの話を聞きたいとかね
刺激したいでしょ そんなことにお釈迦様は応じません
苦しみをなくす方法だけ教えたんです
一切を知ることは不可能ですが
必ず知るべきもの 人が要求するすべてを語ったので
聞く人は満足するのです
一切知ることは不可能です
その代わりにどうしても知らなくちゃいけないこと
欠かせないものだけを教える
だから聞く人々はすごい満足する
仏教は何でも知りたいのではなく
知るべきものを必ず知る世界観です
何でも知りたい方々は他の宗教に行ってください
仏教はもうダメですね
仏教は知るべきことだけを教える
終わりと思います 最後にと言えども
コミュニケーションが成り立たないです
病と死を避けられないが
我々は諦めずに工夫して生きているでしょ
...コミュニケーションの問題もその程度のことだと理解しておきましょう
それが結論です 我々は病気にならないようにね
頑張ってますけどね 病気になりますよ
でも諦めないでしょ だからコミュニケーションしっかりしましょうと頑張ってください
でもうまくいかないんです
サッチャンバネナーリカン
嘘ではなく真実のみを語れっていう言葉で終了いたします
それブッダの言葉 はい
時間ないです どうもありがとうございます
どうもありがとうございます
今日は少し時間のほう押してしまいましたので
質疑応答は簡裁させていただきたいなと思います
それではあの  じゃあ祝福の偈を唱えますので
ご唱和ください サッビーティーヨーイワッジャンツーサンブローゴーウィナッセットーマーテーバワットアンテラーヨーシティディーラーイコーバウェーバワトゥサ
ッブェマンガランガッカントゥサッブェデーヴァタサッブェブッダヌーバヴェーナサッブェナンマーヌーバヴェーナサッブェサンガーヌーバヴェーナサダーソッティバ
ワントゥテーアビワーダナシーリスーニッチャンワッターパジャイノーチャッターローダンマーワッダンティーアーイワンノーシュカンバランアーユラーローゲサンパッ
ティサッブェサンパッティメーウィチェアトゥーニッバーナサンパッティイミナーテーサミッジュトゥ
どうもありがとうございます
今日は大失敗 時間オーバーしてしまい
申し訳ありません  そういうわけで諦めずまたあげてください